first set of questions are regarding
learning more than one language at the
same time this is something that many
webinar attendees were very interested
in and it seems like to me they're so I
don't they do not have any time and they
want to reach language goals as fast as
possible and the only way to do that is
to start learning two languages at a
time so with a Melanie and William asked
can you learn more than one language at
it over at at the same time or is it
better to learn one Lang one language at
the time or and should you start the
next language once you've reached a
certain ability level or are you overall
faster if you're learning their language
is simultaneously what is your take on
that
well it's it's a pretty general question
I would say that it really depends on
the individual and on a number of
factors but normally for a person
doesn't have that much experience in
language learning I always suggest they
learn just one language at a time now
imagine that you have 10 years you have
a time budget of 10 years to learn 10
languages right so if you if you think
okay I'm going to start 10 languages at
the same time because you know I have 10
years if I people tend to think some
people tend to think that if they do
things at the same time they may
actually gain time you know they earn
time at doing that but in length
especially in language learning that is
not quite true
first because when you tackle two
languages at the same time what happens
is that we build course we build
language course now it's not just a
problem a problem of how many words we
know and how we assemble together but
it's also a matter of feelings and
emotions and experiences that come with
that language and if we learn two
languages or three or four or even ten
at the same time what happens is that
sometimes they tend to mingle in your in
your head and you tend to confuse them
sometimes threads especially when you
try to learn two languages up to two
languages that are similar let's suppose
that as an American
you want to learn Italian Spanish and
French at the same time I also remember
vividly remember conversation with
Richard Richard is a fellow polygon who
told me that the University when he when
he started learning for example
Portuguese Spanish and in French if I if
memory serves me if I remember correctly
he said in most students were actually
very confused because they were trying
to tackle very similar languages
languages tend to overlap for a number
of reasons for example Italian and
Spanish 2/10 overlap for pronunciation
because it's in a way it's very similar
and anole morphology as well like very
many words are pretty similar so I would
say first I suggest you learn just one
language at a time because as I said
before imagine if you have ten years if
you learn for example two languages at
the same time for two years and then you
move on to other languages then you
develop a certain capacity in your choir
and ability form a language score in a
certain language that is going to help
you learn another language when two
languages are similar if you for example
decide to learn a German and Spanish at
the beginning and after a couple years
to try to tackle a time it will be much
easier maybe at the beginning you're
going to confuse them a little bit but
the fact that you have acquired a
language core so to say so a structure a
layer in one language it gives you a lot
of help when it comes to building
another language core which is in a way
similar while if you try to build two
language cores that are similar at the
same time they're going to overlap so as
a general guideline I would say first if
you really want to learn multiple
languages at the same time I would say
that two is the amount the max right huh
so try to maybe two languages so choose
a maximum of two languages at any given
time then choose two languages that are
possibly distinct from one another so
they're different because as I said
before if they're similar they can
overlap in by way words grammar emotions
memories etc etc I try to use another
another thing useful piece of advice is
try to choose an easy language and a
relatively
got one now easy and difficult you know
it would take a century to explain the
definition of that but I would say that
by easy language I would say that it's a
language that is similar in so many ways
to yours that an example is England for
example English and Dutch in Dutch is
considered one of the easiest language
for native English speakers for a number
of reasons or a time Spanish and Italian
for example or in Spanish and Portuguese
and and another thing is once you've
decided to you have an easy language in
a difficult one you can organize your
time accordingly and better because for
example you can dedicate 70 to 80
percent of your time to the difficult
language and 20-30 percent of your time
to an easy an easy language that
requires less effort you know and I did
that for example when I started learning
Portuguese and Chinese I dedicated 80
percent of my time to Chinese but I also
allocated some time to Portuguese at the
end of my Chinese session I started
learning a little bit of Portuguese and
that was very helpful because just
fifteen to thirty minutes a day of
Portuguese help me you know in six
months I was already fluent because
Portuguese is very very similar to
Spanish a language that I already learn
if I learn Portuguese and Spanish at the
same time it would have been a disaster
for my brain and the last thing that I
wanted to add is that when you learn two
languages at the same time remember to
study both of them every day so don't do
any sort of rotation meaning you study a
language for a week and then you study
another language
the next week because as I said before
you have to give your brain the
possibility of growing and by doing if
you want to do if you want that to
happen you have to give it every day
some pieces of information you know if
you for example you study a language for
one week and then you study another one
what about the first language during the
second week you're not going to do
anything so it Ted you did the amount of
information that you that you accumulate
in your brain is goes down and then you
have to take it back again so right
organizing your time efficiently it's
very important and try to study every
single day both languages the more
languages you learn obviously the more
time you need the more time and energy
you need so just as
what kind of investment you want to make
to make and if you have maybe 10 hours a
day to study languages then you can you
can possibly tackle 3 for language
nobody nobody can keep you from doing
that but remember that the more
languages you learn the more difficult
it gets to organize your time and not to
mix languages